well we want to go from thinking about
the horizontal stuff to well I'm not
actually moving mainly in horizontal and
vertical directions like I'm moving
around this thing and you may recall at
any given point like my velocity at this
point it's going off on a tangent like
literally it's going off on a tangent
right so I don't want to think about the
up/down I want to figure out how they
relate to round and round okay so the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to illustrate these two forces onto this
diagram here's a point okay and I'm
going to put the X force well it's going
to be going in this direction okay the
reason why it has to be this direction
is because if I'm on a Cartesian plane
you know how usually in a are in a
mechanic's question forces a lot of
times we kind of decide oh I'm going to
make positive this way I'm going to make
positive this way or whatever but once
you're on a Cartesian plane positive and
negative kind of already been decided
for you haven't you that's got to be
positive oh that's got to be positive
right so this force is facing in this
direction now keep in mind it's a minus
sign right so therefore the resultant
force is actually going in that way all
right but I have to draw the line this
way so that the - makes sense okay so
this force is the horizontal force okay
now I have also a vertical force so I'll
put that up like this
now I'm trying to think of this in terms
of not just horizontal and vertical but
round and round okay so here we go to
another color what I want to think about
is there's going to be a tangent force
right when I add these two up there's
going to be a force that's pushing me
around okay so I'm going to put in some
sort of like a tangent access if you
like something like this I guess that's
a terrible tangent but you get the idea
okay so there's a force that's going
this way and then there's also a force
that's kind of relative to the center
right so it's going kind of like this oh
I missed well it's close enough okay
so you've got a tangential force
okay so we'll call this our our tangent
axis if you like now on a second if this
is a tangent axis make sense but what do
you think you would call what's a
suitable name using the language that we
know from this other axis that's
perpendicular to it probably the normal
right it's the normal to the circle you
can see it's perpendicular it's May
degrees there okay so along this axis
I'm going to have a tangent force okay
um let's call that direction of motion
this way it tends to be that way so I've
got my F I'll make a capital T this way
there's a force going that way
and there's also a force going this way
this is the normal okay I'm making
positive away from the origin because it
makes me further away from the origin if
that makes sense so positive this way
and I've got positive this way okay so
far so good so now my question is how do
I relate these two forces in terms of
these two forces if you want to think
about it this way remember when we were
doing on volumes right and if you get a
volume that's weird shaped something
like this
do you remember this guy right so you
take the hyperbola right and then you
say oh let's take the line y equals x
instead right because we can rotate it
around that or we can still form a ball
of you like we did that okay but here
you could see that instead of having
well x and y then it's not very useful
to slice the shape across that way you
don't get useful cross-section you don't
get slices and you don't get similar
things and you don't get shells you get
nothing useful so that's why we changed
it in terms of is we call that kind of
like the height answers right so doing
exactly the same thing here we're
converting horizontal vertical into
tangent and normal right so what we're
going to need is some trig Q color
number three all right
so for instance let's just think about
this horizontal force can you see that
the horizontal force contributes some to
the normal and some to the tangent okay
and you can show that with some fancy
triangles okay so here we go I've got
this
about this
okay so what am I just drawn in red what
I've just drawn in red is how much of
the horizontal force contributes this
direction and how much of the horizontal
force contributes this direction to each
of these two new axes that are defining
okay now in order to convert from this
to realize okay part of it over here and
plants over here I'm gonna need some
trig to help me okay so we already know
that we're defining feeder right as your
angle around and around and around right
so that would be here I guess there's
theta okay at the same time I suppose
even though it's not super relevant but
where we're going around in this
direction right and that angular
velocity that's omega so I've got that
going ball okay now if that's where
feeder ears that's where theta is where
else is feeder up here that is useful to
then have a look okay I keep in mind you
can mix axis here and then you've got
the force in the X direction so these
two lines are parallel does that make
sense right
so therefore where do you see theta is
theta now with you I can see people
pointing it would help if I had some
letters here right and the textbook in
fact does put letters it's like you know
ABCD efg you know I'm avoiding putting
those on because stuck the diagram just
kind of dies when you put all like a
hundred letters on there I think you can
see there's corresponding angles on
parallel lines so I see a feed up there
does that make sense
okay now that means that I can work out
what this force is over here okay
because what you've got is I've formed
some right-angled triangles in here
you're all these forces that are
perpendicular to each other that's why
I'm resolving okay now just have a look
in this little triangle have a look in
this little try to I draw it over here
if you like
okay now you've got the horizontal force
going this way so this side has this
length because remember the length of
this is is important it represents how
much force there is if it was little
it'd be a very small force okay so
that's FX and I'm trying to find out
what this is right and I've already
determined through tree that that's or
sorry through geometry but that's the
how would you express that side that
force question mark
I've got um I've got a right angle
triangle I can just use right angle
triangle tree color what's the ratio
that relates these two sides its cause
right cause of theta is adjacent on
hypotenuse right
so therefore this unknown side which
represents this force along the normal
direction away from the origin but that
force is f X cos theta that's the part
of the horizontal force that's going in
that direction okay so let me put that
in in color F X cause fear okay that's
good but I'm not done yet I want to know
about the part of this because there's
another part that's going in this
direction along these tangent answers
right how am I going to work it out we
use corresponding angles to get from
here to here right what else can I use
look carefully I can do um surely I can
do simple turn angles as well right
because all these things are
perpendicular parallel it looks to me
like I have a theater here and see that
all set angles there's your and your
zippers are okay so I can do the same
thing I can replant or save you a bit of
time you're going to get F X sine video
in that direction okay you can you can
join yourself up a new triangle just
like this but it's not that hard to see
okay